we're back with a quick episode three
preview looking for clues as to what
next week's episode might have in store
so if you haven't seen the preview yet
I've left a link in the description
below
so take a look and come on back the
preview begins where episode 2 left off
what appears to be mr. jingles bangs on
the door but as we figured out this
season when it comes to mr. jingles it
really could be anyone we did see him
creeping outside the cabin near the end
of episode 2 but it could be Margaret in
the raincoat or one of these other dudes
that we've seen in previous preview
videos it's also entirely possible that
this is a fake out and won't be jingles
at all Xavier feels responsible for the
death of Blake last episode and believes
whatever is behind that door is karma
for that death here's a cool shot of mr.
jingles at what is likely the insane
asylum notice the recorder there as if
he's being prepped for an interview most
likely from chief psychologist dr.
hopple who we see here yes she's back
and what has to be a flashback since she
was killed last episode and tells us
that there's almost always a method to a
killer's madness but with jingles some
people are just evil this is another
allusion to Michael Myers in Halloween
we also don't know who she's talking to
here perhaps whoever is interviewing
jingles isn't hopple rather than this
mystery person inside the boathouse we
have this woman who we saw in the season
to come preview now maybe you guys can
help me out but is she wearing a 70's
80's dress or is this a nurse's outfit
the title for episode 3 is /dance which
could be referring to some sort of dance
and we're not sure if this takes place
in the past or present whatever way you
slice it it looks like jingles will be
slicing her okay I'll shut up Xavier in
Montana run so it looks like they got
out of that situation from the end of
episode 2 and here we have Brooke
running with what appears to be Rita
ahead of her so they also get out of
their situation we get this cool shot of
jingles coming up from the forest with
his axe my guess is that someone is
getting away on a motorcycle and jingles
is there to behead them here's the Night
Stalker outside the infirmary freaking
the hell out of Rita and the others
unless this is a fake out it's safe to
assume also taking into consideration he
went in the direction of the infirmary
last episode that he is the one knocking
on their door I am the one who knocks
this is also an important clip here we
have ray and Chet falling into what is
most likely the pit of spikes notice
also that Ray has some blood on his
shoulder here which could be from the
altercation earlier in the episode
Xavier and Trevor later find them saying
what the hell are you doing down there -
which Chet responds I'm dying it's
probably from this clip from a previous
preview so nothing too major to report
here it looks like our gang of
counselors make it out from whomever was
banging on the doors only to confront
new dangers I'm hoping you'll join me
for more Aegis videos and be sure to
check out my episode 2 breakdown if you
haven't already
every like comment and subscription
helps and you can follow me on twitter
at ping story YT until next time
remember daddy loves you very much